can I like throw this in the crowd it's
not like we yeah we're
[Applause]
fine right I will see all of you this
evening I expect all six of you who
caught that to flip it on eBay tonight I
will be
fitting I love you be friends I hope
you're enjoying thank
you I dat trade attention and build
businesses Legacy is greater than
currency I'm a pure bread entrepreneur
for real for real for real like
documented morning morning coffee
morning morning morning morning it's
just such a pleasure to be with with all
of you I just want to thank you for
being here so early who worked out
already this morning just curious I'm
impressed where were I'm impressed I
wasn't there I'm impressed though but um
we have we have an incredible day uh in
the stadium uh I'm I'm here to sign a
whole bunch of
[Music]
stuff how are you good oh oh hold on
we're coming back one second I'm trying
to get we're back that's what I was
looking
for I know baby but I can't wait to see
you next year I can't wait I'm counting
down the days of seeing you next year so
I started following your ADV talk my
business has blown up and it has never
been the same since so I just want to
say thank you so
much thank you I need examples like you
for them because they don't [__] tell
them they don't listen so I started
following Gary's advice my business blew
up on Tik Tok about 6 months ago and my
life has been forever changed and we
just sold out of our third shipment
again I'll see you there is there stairs
can I
[Music]
jump
we are handing out
mimosas I want to make sure everyone
gets one hey everybody I'm Gary
vaynerchuk uh creator of V friends I
just wanted to take 5 seconds before day
two officially kicks off I know I got to
meet a bunch of you already this morning
but I just want to say thank you thank
you for supporting this thank you for
being a part of it if you find yourself
being introvert and you want to like try
and practice getting to be out there and
put yourself out there there's no safer
place than this weekend to start that
process for you so keep that in mind I
love you all thank you for being here
enjoy personally a big fan and born and
raised here in Indie so a thank you very
much for being here and as a token of
our appreciation I'll give a little
backstory just as this is your second
conference and you're getting things
rolling the Jets are actually the first
game here in Indianapolis this so as the
way that the Jets kind of helped us get
on the map from a football standpoint we
are happy to help you get on the map
from a convention standpoint that a from
the first game here in Indianapolis you
want to hear something crazy I remember
this game vividly because the move was
such a big deal and I just started being
into football and I I was I was nine and
I was like wait teams can move towns it
was like a big to-do and I remember this
this game so vividly cuz it was the
first game of the season that year I was
super nervous thank you thank you this
is
unbelievable I if you know me like
something like this is like 87 times
more exciting than something small
Freeman mcneel I remember thank you
pleas very nice pleas I really cherish
this this is really
[Music]
nice I got to get a quick look at all
this
[Music]
[Applause]
yo first I just want to thank every for
being here I'm so excited about 2023 how
did we feel about last
night watching all of you interact with
each other yesterday was by far the best
part of the conference for me and so I
want everyone to be as loud as humanly
possible for each other right now and I
want to keep that
going
louder one thing that I've
noticed from a lot of you is that you
reach out to me around family business
Dynamics a very big theme a lot of you
are pondering it and what I really know
is that this audience is grooming a lot
of their own business partners who
happen to be their children right now as
entrepreneurship and side hustles and
family business Dynamics are growing in
society so knowing so many of you are on
this journey right now and knowing so
many of you will be on this journey in
the future I thought there was no better
way than to kick off Eon than to have
Sasha and AJ vaynerchuk join me up
[Applause]
here love
you
love you
[Music]
s
strangers become
acquaintances acquaintances become
friends friends become
family I have a very strong feeling that
many of the faces that I can see right
now in the crowd that I flat out already
know and know a lot of about you are
destined to become family with each
other and with this community and with
myself and so I thought it was
incredibly important to start Von
2023 with family I thank you for sitting
through our stories I just want you to
please please be friends with each other
that is the biggest Roi of this project
I thank Sasha my dad AJ my brother and I
thank all of you most for being here at
beon thank you's
go thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you brother made it again snuck in yeah
I like it let's go keep doing it it's
packed in
[Music]
here
how are you good how are you good to see
you I'm 24 okay and I really really
really struggle with self-love so that
comes from parenting or environment
parents definitely that's okay that's
therapy that's surrounding yourself with
positivity you're in control of getting
yourself out there's like that's not
like bad by the way that's normal right
that's what everyone's dealing with so
don't be dwelling on that be happy that
you know it the only difference between
you and most people is you figured it
out
already most people haven't even started
the Journey of understanding they don't
love themselves you're way ahead oh
thanks yeah most people who are like
wait a minute I don't have self-love I
don't have confidence they think they're
behind they're
ahead nobody there's such a small amount
of people that are as lucky as I was
which is why I speak with caution when I
talk about this I got lucky with parents
and with circumstances that I had self-
Lov but like most people don't and even
I've had to work through my
insecurities yeah you're do you
understand how lucky you are that you
know yeah do you yeah well now I do
def FR you're ahead thanks so much not
behind thank you therapy if you can
afford it or just get positivity in your
[__] ears that's what I need more
more of that ingesting it and do not
surround your you have to cut out your
friends you have to limit the time you
interact with the negative people in
your life yeah that's my problem like if
if one of your parents or both your
parents are negative you got to speak to
them once a week not three times a day
right if you're three best friends if
one of them is negative you got to start
to cut that down you have to cut down
negativity and you have to pump in
positivity that's the only way that's
the
[Music]
work
badly here's the only perfect card right
now
[__] it's [__]
[Music]
fire all right I'll take a Gary B I love
it good
choice I'll take the astronaut okay and
the panda panda this is and Nar this is
narwa
yep beautiful all right bring me
up he don't forget we got to do that
interview when you come back to New York
okay I can't wait to do it can't wait
thank you so much of course app welcome
to the Von stage Ki
coie
[Music]
G
brother hi y'all I'm kidi K and I am the
chief marketing officer for
Jess FR yes it's good to see all of you
um can you guys give us a little taste
of what might be coming
Heidi you want me to jump on this one
all right so obviously pop culture
what's actually happening in the now
matters quite a bit I I'm sure that
anybody here that pays attention to the
Croc Universe understands that the
jibbitz culture is a big deal and that
many of you have nieces nephews friends
and yourself collecting jibit so uh
clearly we are on stage I have no idea
you know if you can see this but we've
got some Crocs on that have some jibit
on them and if it zooms in nicely you
can tell those are vriends jibit so I'm
excited about this quite a
bit you know when I think about
extending the IP and creating
storytelling this this was kind of a
Northstar collaboration for me and so
this is a a little bit of a preview I
think we've got some more things brewing
and so I think it should be a good fall
or winter or whatever our timing gets
down but we definitely have some stuff
Brewing can I like throw this in the
crowd it's not like we we're fine so I
think I yeah I I think I think I'm going
to throw all six pairs of the first
pairs with jibit got it in the crowd so
I'm going to do that here we
go
W all right I will see all of you this
evening I expect all six of you who
caught that to flip it on eBay tonight I
will be
bidding I love you be friends I hope
you're enjoying thank
[Music]
you
I just want to thank Harry mes for
hosting us I want to thank video amp for
being an incredible partner for us thank
you
[Music]
everyone for me what vriends is is my
opportunity for next 50 years to get
those characters to matter to do my work
for me that's why this matters so much
for me like if I can get the world to
fall in love with accountable ant like I
can tell you right now every person here
would be twice as happy if they went
fully accountable if everything that's
bothering you right now in a personal
relationship or professionally you
decide it was actually your fault and
nobody else's your life would be 10
times
better
got sh in here we told you this was be
that's Mr Vayner
Chuck I love you I thought it was one
second annual Von
2023 the first year was good so far this
blows it out of the water and do you
know why can't wait for year three do
you know why beon 24 is going to be the
best because when we all get together
for a private flyfish event everybody
would have already experienced fly fish
which I'm really looking forward to oh
yeah because speaking about
working oh happy
[Music]
holidays we should probably go we should
probably go on tour yeah we should do
let's see how today goes yeah we may
never talk
[Music]
again shout out to Von shout out to
Gary it is amazing what uh he has
built it really is amazing what he's
built can I tell where this was supposed
to be y yeah all right this was actually
supposed to be in a bigger
venue we were actually supposed to do it
on Gary's forehead but the problem we
going to do it on the forehead but
there's not enough people in Indiana to
fill
[Music]
that what we do now let's get on our
feet and welcome back to the Deon
VI Gary
bner put the money on the wood and if I
would lock oh there we go I heard that
crack putting other people's opinions of
yourself in front of yours then they go
to me but Gary what if it's my opinion
of myself that I suck then I remind them
that that was instilled in
[Music]
you
he